previously on tv since do you have any
last words
i love lamp
[Music]
i'm tired of sending the two full
minutes of opening credits so let's ding
hbo for the fact that this static intro
bumper hasn't changed in 22 years
seriously i don't know if i'm watching
game of thrones or dream on also what
kind of lazy media company uses the
sound of static as a transition
lame show opens on 13 seconds of every
single [ __ ] step of loading a
catapult if i can't sling a pumpkin more
than 3636 feet with today's torque tech
then i call shenanigans on these ships
launching giant flaming projectiles this
far into the city
also these trebuchets are on boats i
want this to work but these are not
seaworthy weapons the counterweights to
fling these stones would wreak havoc on
the ship and rock it around like it's
brawn in a brothel dany has just
returned from a
a dryad inspired renfest b a tryout for
the wwe or
c coachella no ruler that ever lived had
the support of all the people
clearly game of thrones has never been
privy to one king ralph i will crucify
the masters i will set their fleets of
fire
kill every last one of their soldiers
and return their cities to the dirt and
this is game of thrones version of one
of the good guys
the dragons beneath the great pyramid
will be slaughtered man what the masters
lack in charm they sure do make up for
it with guyliner
your reign is over drogon flying towards
these arrogant bricks in the distance is
just the best i will always admire a
show that's somehow able to be subtle
and kick-ass hyperbolic in the same
scene
my reign has just begun also in addition
to being badass it's also a tad
confusing does daenerys have drogon
remote controlled by distant one-liners
also also this is a great moment at all
but
sudden dragon like drogon barely made a
peep before he revealed himself
also also were the masters not expecting
this even if they'd never seen a dragon
in action they do know that daenerys has
dragons damn it
everyone's scared of dragons carl jim
brandon you're doing a great job holding
the weapons and crouching but your
interest in this scene
is the huge [ __ ] dragon on your left
not your buddies on the other side of
the set
extras i know game of thrones like to
drag its ass i mean story lines out as
long as possible but tyrion unchained
those dragons at the beginning of the
season have they seriously just been
biting their time in the dungeon until
the masters decided to show up and wage
war which no one knew was going to
happen
also look at that dothraki horde the
majesty the passion the invulnerability
good thing they're not going anywhere
dracarys um i'm sorry danny but it's
pronounced avada kadavra
thank you for the armada our queen does
love ships
except for these these in particular
good thing he knelt and the other two
just happened to be standing within
arm's reach otherwise grey worm would
have been able to gray worm so
effectively
tell your people what happened here tell
them you live by the grace of her
majesty
won't this be the third time they've
tried this tactic i get you can't just
kill everyone but maybe tyrion should've
let daenerys have her way this
time she basically did everything she
said she wanted to do except kill this
one master you know a show is tapped out
of wardrobe creativity when a man wears
an accordion pleated monstrosity such as
this
you don't have the men you don't have
the horses and you don't have winterfell
but he does have incredibly precise
stitches never underestimate a man with
a plastic surgeon in his ranks
and you're all fine looking men my dogs
are desperate to meet you
i mean game of thrones has a lot of evil
[ __ ] villains but ramsay is the only
one that i could literally see twirling
his mustache during every line i haven't
fed them for seven days they're ravenous
foreshadowing jesus i think jon
seriously thinks he can win this
showdown by sexually staring ramsay to
death
they won't be able to hit us the way
that's done this hit you in a double
envelopment
a pincer move i once suggested a double
envelope and a pincer move on the very
same night
and that's the story of how my college
girlfriend became my former college
girlfriend
did it ever once occur to you that i
might have some insight
it's true john you should totally
confide in sansa and there's no way that
will ever backfire on you someday what
have i been doing all my life playing
with broomsticks based on your
commitment to celibacy until recently i
would imagine that's exactly what you've
been doing most of your life
maybe that was our mistake believing in
kings jon snow's not the king we hate
kings but we love jon snow because he
can't be a king and simultaneously
wish there was a way for jon to be king
while also preparing ourselves
emotionally because this is game of
thrones and at any moment jon is apt to
die a horrible death
the one thing i really want game of
thrones to explain to me is who gets
stuck carrying all this
furniture on these long travels did
melisandre really need that mirror chair
and the fire pit wait is she dripping
look at those huge pupils now that i
think of it interpreting flames
is something people do with those
festivals or so i've heard
and how have things been going for you
since then well if you really want to
know i can tell you in great detail
because if there is one thing this show
does
well it's keeping up to date on the life
and times of theon greyjoy despite the
fact that we barely even cared for him
in season one we all live complicated
lives don't we look peter dinklage is a
fantastic actor don't get me wrong but
some americans just can't quite nail the
british accent and i think we've given
pdink a pass on this show for far too
long and i imagine your offer is free of
any marriage demands
i never demand but i'm up for anything
really this flirting is all wonderful
and i'm sure it provided much needed
fanfic juice for millions but it also
just kind of comes out of nowhere right
no more reeving roving raiding or raping
but what about ravaging rustling risking
retaliating ruining rupturing robbing
ripping ransacking
raising or recklessly removing rotten
raspberries also no more raiding and
raping makes sense but who the hell
cares about a little reeving and roving
i'm sorry mum but we clearly said no
roving so please state your intended
destination and proceed with do haste
and if you could please put away that
rope we will not have you putting that
through a ring on our watch
all this scene is missing is black widow
cocking a gun oh man
ramsay made a barbecue for the visiting
team maybe he's not as bad as i thought
let's play a game run to your brother
last time i played run to your brother
with a ramsay i ended up with a
horseshoe up my ass and marshmallow
cream in my hair
i would like to say i don't have fun
memories of that occasion but here we
are the fact that rickon runs straight
ahead when someone is firing arrows at
him makes so little sense that i hereby
request to the lord of the tv sins light
that from this day forward on this
channel
all straight running students will
attend the rickon stark school of
running away from things
okay let's just pause to reflect on this
poor bastard's passing but also
jon's right there dude you just made
that shot so why wouldn't you take the
leader out in the exact same way
smoldering stairs between hero and
villain right before the battle begins
cliche
holy did jon even like check for a pulse
or anything
i know it looked bad but this is his
brother he couldn't at least drag him
off the battlefield in addition to this
he's gonna get trampled 10 seconds of
horse close-ups good thing jon applied
enough arrow repellent today nothing
beats a good anti-peer spirit the next
20 minutes are absolutely genius
filmmaking by the game of thrones team
and the fact that it's happening on a
television screen is nothing short of
miraculous
take your sins off you beautiful bastard
you huh john must have developed
the same selective hearing that the
masters had before drogon snuck upon
them i know he's hyper focused but he
didn't hear the goddamn army right
behind him
no who's there even amidst the confusion
of battle the show does an incredible
job of keeping the geography and
intention clear
fabulous action editing at least we know
that thrones will understand the
importance of being able to actually see
and follow things the next time there's
a big battle outside the gates of
winterfell right when crowdsurfing goes
terribly wrong
awesome it's the writers of rohan or
something seriously what took these
[ __ ] so long
also sansa wrote the littlefinger a few
episodes back asking for aid and failed
to mention it to jon why
what good would it do to withhold even
the possibility of this tide changing
ally i get that sansa just leveled up by
pulling this deus veil machina and
everything but isn't it a bit premature
smile abrasion here considering she
doesn't even know if her brother is
still alive
they don't have the men for siege all we
have to do is wait i get ramsay as a
psychopath and ignorant but he's not
blind the baelish battalion seems like
more than enough for a siege
the only thing worse than seeing horses
perished by the hundreds on a
battlefield is watching one of the last
giants die
one one is done done you suggested
one-on-one combat didn't you
i've reconsidered this works for even a
second i like to think that jon looks
back on this moment
fondly as the bolton bash but then he
probably doesn't give me credit for
coming up with the name
i'm gonna bury my brother in the crypt
next to my father
as opposed to what an unmarked grave in
the back forty
literally everyone in this world would
know that the stark bloodline should be
buried with their ancestors who needed
to be reminded of this other than the
audience
[Music]
sansa seems to have the dramatic timing
abilities down with dogs like daenerys
does with her dragons
oh who's a good boy who's a hungry boy
who's gonna need a big face
you are i realize this probably makes me
morbid but
sheesh igor i think he chewed your ear
off
kill every last one of their soldiers
and return their cities to the dirt
tell your people what happened here you
tell them i'm coming
and hell's coming with me you here sleep
well i most like to kill you in the
morning
you saw these demons what
no it's a manner of speaking his people
are completely literal metaphors are
gonna go over his head
nothing goes over my head my reflexes
are too fast
any advice hey i don't have all the
answers
in life to be honest i failed
as much as i've succeeded the sooner you
make it to him
the sooner you get to see him again it's
a trap